خيبه امل اوكرانيه بعد ما فشلت الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه باقناع برلين لارسال دبابات
ليوبار اليها رغم الضغوط الدوليه
والداخليه ولكن لماذا تتمسك اوكرانيا
بدبابات نيوبار الالمانيه اكثر من ابرامز
الامريكيه هذه الدبابات مشاهدينا تعد
الاقوى في العالم بعد ابرامز الامريكي
تشغلها وصيانتها اسال بكثير من الدبابات
الامريكيه التي تحتاج الى وقود طائره اما
الدبابات الالمانيه الصنع فتحتاج الى
الديزل لتشغيلها
وتقتصد اكثر في المصروف نتحدثون عن الطاقه
من الدبابه الامريكيه وفق الخبراء
العسكريه لا يطير الالمانيه هي ايضا اخف
وزنا واسرع حركه ويمكنها ان تصيب اهداف
ادق وابعد من ابرز وهذا الامر اشار اليه
واشنطن سابقا عندما قالت ان الصعوبات
التقنيه هو سبب الرئيسي لرفض ارسال واشنطن
لدبابات
دبابات لايوبارت 2 بدا تصنيعها عام 1979
في المانيا الغربيه كدبابات قتال رئيسيه
يمكنها التصدي للدبابات السوفياتيه طبعا
ايام الحرب البارده التقديرات العسكريه
مشاهدينا تشير الى وجود نحو
1150 دبابات ليوبار لا ده الدول الاوروبيه
من بينها طبعا المانيا فيما تطالب
اوكرانيا ب100 من هذه الدبابات وتقول انها
ستكون كافيه لردع الهجوم الروسيه وشنها
جمال لاستعاده الاراضي الاكاليه دول
البطيخ كلاديا واستونيا وليتوانيا وجهه
دعوه مشتركه الى المانيا لارسال
الدباباتها الرئيسيه الى اوكرانيا لمساعده
اكياس طبعا في حربها ضد روسيا ولكنها برين
تتخوف من رد فعل روسيه
امكانيه ان تعتبر روسيا ارسال هذه
الدبابات الى كاف تصعيدا في الحرب مما يت
طبعا باذى لالمانيا مباشره لقد يعرضها
لانتقام روسيا